um
now help me okay let's clear up this
this this situation
i saw you just post that vlad headline
that was missing right
yeah so for people who don't know you
originally were signed
um i think a lot of people were
introduced to you through boozy
yeah yeah yeah right you were on the the
bupok album and
um boozy was he the first guy who really
kind of like came in and co-signed you
as far as like
oh yeah for sure and coming out of
alabama i know booze is not from alabama
but boozy in the south is like [ __ ]
jesus christ yeah himself
or so um so
there was the headline that said that
you were no longer with boozy's label
and you're with dream chasers now
yeah so and can you clear that whole
situation up
uh man that situation was just a
misunderstanding i i
i really like how the headline looked
because it seemed like on some
switching teams type type stuff like i
said uh
you know just like the clip that he
posted
within like if you read the story it'll
show you that i said that i told that i
came to boost i was like i ain't really
like us
rocking with colombia no more because
you know they weren't really doing
what i needed them to do for me you know
what i'm saying so i was like
we was joint venture with them a lot of
people don't know that like i was joint
venture with
me boosting columbia records like six
months after i signed to him so
uh you know after about you know some
years just like i said they really
understand the wave i had going on
so i just felt like it was best to just
go independent and when i say
independent
you know boosted labor independent you
know what i'm saying so
we independent you know since i'm trying
to i ain't
switched to when i say i got off the
label
i'm always talking about columbus
columbia yeah i'm not talking about
boosters
are you still signing the boozies yeah
yeah imprint yeah i'm still signing a
booster like we just
amended some things like after that
kaduna deal we had to sit back doc i was
a bigger artist you know what i'm saying
so we
amended some things you know i told him
like kind of like my vision
you know so no i think that's dope too
like
a lot of times right you signed that
deal early with an artist like you know
another artist yeah and like you know
hey man i'm at a different place now
mm-hmm
the fact and boozy was open to that
conversation yeah because it wasn't like
no
it wasn't it wasn't like saying i'm at a
different place now i don't want to be
assigned to your label no more
right but like he could be he could be
an [ __ ] and be like look you signed
what you signed
yeah that tells you how real how real of
a [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying so you know
we amended some things you know boosters
still get his
percentage like just had our original
contract set up is just that you know
saying i
own my masters and stuff like that
that's dope [ __ ] people a lot of people
don't know like [ __ ]
for that deal it's a lot of business for
that deal to get them in it's a lot of
business i did
you know what i'm saying to to to get
that to that point you know it wasn't
just
i mean we we we good we found but at the
same time like i gave
up all my like 100 of my
early masters during that time
to be able to own a hundred percent of
my future stuff you know what i'm saying
so i gave booster like
all the mixtapes and stuff i dropped
with booster like boosted like get out
of the masters yeah he owned a message
to those you know what i'm saying
so these so essentially you said hey you
could have these masters if you
just let me move the way i want to move
moving forward yeah because i had like
three four albums left with him so
it's like he could have said you know
what i'm saying no you know what i'm
saying like
i'm my own knees too you know what i'm
saying but uh
like i said you know what i'm saying
like it was it was it was
it was willing to dylan you know what
i'm saying so now i mean look
i think you know there's
with you know kanye's been on his his
[ __ ] lately with the masters and just
record deals and i think
major labels won't even let you do that
like you can't go now i was gonna say
like i think that's some real [ __ ] when
like if you think of like boozy like you
know obviously you signed whatever you
signed
yeah and for him to be like open to just
like hey man look if
you're obviously in a different place
than when i met you yeah like let's move
differently moving forward yeah
and plus you know like i said the basic
of the contract
still the same you know what i'm saying
it's just that you know saying i i have
you know i could do what i want you know
what i'm saying
basically but you know he's still
getting the same now like if i go over
here
if i go sign with uh if i want to go
sign up i'll go sign with uh
atlantic and you still get
y'all the next album blow up and sell a
million copies you know what i'm saying
he's still gonna get fifty percent of
that you know what i'm saying for the
same amount
yeah fifty damn he got the fifty all
right because that's what was the
original contract
i got you i got you and you owe him
three or four more albums
uh yeah yeah yeah so let me ask you this
then what what because i know meat [ __ ]
with you heavy what is the actual
official
affiliation the meat situation came
about
uh and also just the the backtrack one
one one thing like go ahead the being
boosted situation okay it's it's it's 50
of you know what i'm saying it's like a
profit participation it's like
you know saying uh you know
i'm giving i'm giving you 50 because
this
this was the original contract but okay
in the original contract then i couldn't
have been able to go
if somebody wanted to give me a million
dollars over here you know i'm saying i
couldn't have
technically i couldn't sign that deal
you know what i'm saying now you're
getting
yeah but now i can you so so i feel like
i gave up i had to give up something to
get able to yeah because i know i'm
gonna drop yeah i'm gonna drop
mo music i know i'm gonna drop you bang
out three or four projects in a year if
you're yeah
you know what i'm saying but moving fast
moving fast forward so we
me and him talked about the the uh the
meat situation you know meat
team uh came to me you know sherry brian
over there uh that's actually the
president of the roc nation so she came
to me
and it was just you know laid out a
situation on the table to where
i felt like at the time made sense you
know it was a management situation
where she was just like you know we can
help you with a you know a lot of stuff
of course
um and it was like
you know i looked it over we talked
about it for a couple months
i went i flew down that up meet with me
and still i talked about it with booster
you know
saying he felt like it was you know what
i'm saying it'll be good because him and
me good you know what i'm saying so
that's what that situation was it wasn't
like no all right booster you know what
i'm saying
let me go over here to meet nah like
that so meek's
team is management yeah yeah that's
what's up
they're part of the management how did
um how did mika
like what would you know like what the
original record was that like caught
meek's attention or that like brought
him made him a fan of yours
i think i think it was more i think it
was more meat team
like it was more meat team you know what
i'm saying presented to me
and then because they were like yo this
kid's moving we should work with him
mike
yeah you know what i'm saying i honest i
honestly don't
i honestly don't really too much know if
no because meek from a whole different
you know what i'm saying whole another
part of the
whole other part of the country so i
don't know if he's too much
just understand you know what i'm saying
my music so much
as as of yet you feel me but i feel like
you know
i can't i came in for what i you know i
feel like his team you know saying his
team was presented to me and what they
could do you know so i ain't coming to
ride meek way you know all right his
coattail you know
i came in for i think that's just kind
of the misunderstanding i think is like
people just see it people see a headline
and that's what they go with yeah you
know what i'm saying
so yeah it's important to clear that
[ __ ] up